this is actual rocket scientist min 1687
an hour an hour striking this person
performing brain surgery
hey brought here a police to 420 saw
this video it was being shared for some
reason it came out in September yeah
this video was being shared again making
the rounds because someone in my
timeline said I'm really thankful this
year to not be in the in the slavery
based tipping industry service something
like that really upset and I realize you
know I believe the tipping was rooted in
slavery and that it was unfair and I was
like well it's kinda something we do and
it's fair now because there were videos
like this
there was the Adam ruins everything yeah
I'm tipping what she would want nothing
you just think why would they politicize
it why would they not tell the truth and
that's where today almost everything is
political whether you want it to be or
not I want to ask you a question the day
did you believe the tipping was written
slavery did you believe it was unfair
did you believe a lot of these myths you
heard from Adam ruins everything and
fusion roll clip what if I told you that
tipping has a racist past and it's not
just because black waiters get smaller
tips and their white co-workers or that
the tipped minimum wage just makes the
poor poorer a couple of things will get
to the racist past maybe sometimes I
know D monetize you can hear that black
people tip less yeah
they tip less than a majority of them
actually don't know or agree upon what
the appropriate tip rate is compared to
white people so culturally black people
tend to work in areas where there would
be more black people and they tip less
but that could be a part of it but let's
get into the whole tipping racist
history because this is something a lot
of people believe and at one point I did
as well
it's that the custom of tipping in
America was racist from the very
beginning America racist all the way
back to slave merica slavery being
started
practice in the mid eighteen hundreds
and it spread throughout the country
after the Civil War
so that's sleight of hand I was watching
it hasn't been rooted in slavery racist
in America oh yeah okay thought it was
learning in seventeen hundred years
except so first off that should tip you
off right away that it's actually not
true according to the scholarly work on
the subject tipping began way before
slavery had nothing to do with races and
likely began in the late Middle Ages and
somewhere by the time of Tudor England
and I think 1485 something like that
tipping was commonplace so right off the
bat they want you to think America
racist slavery became a more idea yeah
and even that I wouldn't say is not
entirely accurate its inaccurate X clip
according to research by activists I
wrote a around newly freed slaves were
walking to major cities to find work
properly
this is fusion this is like a major
network on Facebook it's our source a
girl a girl here you go she's in the
feminist thing five she writes rubbing
and post she's a leftist activist so
yeah there you go
no you're cherry-picking no I want you
to go watch this video
you think we're cherry-picking their
sources we're not that's that is their
source there are no sort that's their
source it's their only source next clip
but there were only hired four jobs that
were considered on
yeah how about slaves after after
slavery listen no one is condoning
slavery right anyone in this room right
now hands up condone slavery no okay no
one's condoning slavery but slavery was
a lawful and slavery as you talked about
even with Europe slavery was the norm
people had lived with slavery and now
you've freed slaves and of course they
were unskilled they were telling the
field so it's not perfect but but baby
steps you're not gonna have to count of
monte cristo out of his ten year sense
immediately but if you could get him in
you know like a basement apartment for
months and he probably would've been
taking it as opposed to etching on the
walls no longer a slave so we're trying
to feather into the economy we're gonna
we're gonna do this can you do the
service industry we're not perfect but
we're getting better that's good
racism and classism runs deep yes they
do miss tiramisu on the Upper East Side
rich didn't this is just me boy right
yeah in that like a almost a slur or
something like that like it's not a slur
boy nobody there likes you no boy this
basement there's a connotation but it's
not okay was that your only question all
right this attitude is summed up in this
passage by a reporter in 1902
I never known any Pony growth service it
was take sixty points one expects that
of them it is a token of their
inferiority but to give money to a white
man was embarrassing to me
so John Pedro so I searched high and low
and I could find nary an article from a
John speed in that area listen the Negro
isn't you couldn't just find just
someone to put on some kind of colonial
sound yeah really fusion if you have to
walk over to HR box you have anyone who
can do our narration we've got the man
for you but in the original article from
Johnson was in McBride's magazine here
it isn't it is actually the journalist
was talking about how common white
servers were in the north and he found
that kind of odd because he was from the
south so he'd only seen black service
so again they have one source then
they're talking about this article
taking a paragraph to mean something
that it it's almost the opposite of what
he said in the article huh
that's clear by the late 1880s black
workers accounted for nearly half of the
hospitality industry then in the 20s
restaurants that were losing money
because of prohibition laws encouraged
tipping making it even more popular okay
black Americans accounted for almost
half what about the other more than half
majority or plurality stuff I say who
makes that demographic I'm still looking
for the negative part here they're
giving them money I don't understand
well I just they almost were half I
understand if you look at percentage of
the population but that means more than
half we're not black and actually the
great depression in here but I know it I
know the progression started later in
the 20s but even if you look at
basically the Prohibition right it was a
pair of pression four for industries an
ounce
yeah it was a tough squeeze for them
because you and made your limit units a
pub are off valve all sales and before
the Great Depression they said no no no
none of this for you so for those people
it might as well have been the great
dementia they're funny maybe
cost-cutting measures they could never
think they couldn't serve the thing that
made the money
imagine Abbey's had to survive without
selling their $7 in Britain the 20s they
were all sudden prohibition occur like
can we interest you in a tequila roll no
bathtub Jim in 1996 the then head of the
National Restaurant Association Herman
Cain convinced a republican-led Congress
to seven white supremacists
and none tip workers the tips minimum
wage was set at $2.13 per hour today in
17 states the legal minimum wage for
tipped workers still only two dollars
and 13 cents per hour I just have to
include that because it started out
about it started out based and racism
and slavery and then Herman Cain who was
the black rock Obama where Dimmick
Condoleezza Rice we're going to throw a
ben carson single mother detroit cambia
we're talking about my plane is nine
nine nine get yourself some got his
pizza [ __ ] no look I have a lot of
experience with this I made five dollars
and 25 cents an hour working in this
industry because I made fifteen dollars
an hour average tip share on top of that
guess what if I don't make $2.00 an hour
average I would have moved on somewhere
oh that's exactly what else in this
industry in the industries like it's
kind of like performance-based pay or
certainly performance pay statuses for
teachers the only teachers complaining
about it or crap on credit be teachers
the only servers who are against tips or
yes server working at Waffle House
smoking a joint walking up to the table
it's not working out and I was the
server
you still get crappy tips even has a
good server yeah it still evens out in
your favor
yeah consensus to motivate you it's like
the lowest skilled thing pick up a plate
and walk it over right you're supposed
to be motivated to do better than that
but I don't want to though no so so you
don't this is mystically tipped workers
make an average of 13 dollars per hour
which is obviously way more than the
federal minimum wage of 725 an hour now
let's look at this to the court of the
US Department of Labor the average wage
for all occupations is 1687 an hour okay
yeah so 1687 an hour people in the
service industry who work on tips are
making about $13 never listen they're
not rocket scientists they work hard
this is actual rocket science is made of
1687 an hour I mean ours yours bigger
than striking distance
this person performed brain surgery he
brought here a police to 420 and they
got it wrong twice this tip was ready
it's always runny watch I was gonna say
one no it's the bruiser Jamaican 1600
yes and you guys work hard that's fine
we're not talking about hard work though
talking about skill if you want to be a
server honestly and just you want to get
good tips just be nice yes nice personal
be a jerk and you're like I just I can't
believe that this is and you're tipping
them 15 or 20 percent anyway because you
have to because you know this it's
obviously they make the money off of
tips and you have Adam ruins everything
saying you're a jerk if you don't tip
them but this person really walked up
didn't serve you the food that you
ordered refused to change it and then
charge you for both dishes in the first
place just you want to get tipped well
just being nice that's a start next clip
no white restaurant workers take home 56
percent less than their white peers okay
such a short race she does non what's it
sir that is slavery black ignoring
Europe right ignoring where I had
actions you know Orton ignoring the
Middle Ages
now it's non-white versus white so that
includes everyone who's not white it's
no longer about black and you notice
something here this is just the
restaurant worker comparison yeah yeah
this is this is the Box tactic of just
changing the parameters the definitions
as we go along distantly cheetahs Graham
agree on and then move out exclude
starts with the line so it's a little
kernel of a lie and then it grows into a
popcorn of [ __ ] and this is
restaurant this isn't now it's not only
not about servers it's not about tipped
workers it's just everyone working in
the restaurant field it does that stat
include mislead Michelin star chefs does
it include sous chefs does it include
people who are working as servers or
working as managers at high-end steak
houses this is the total number and they
just say oh by the way whites and
non-whites yeah I looked at the NLRB
stats or the labor review board and they
said that seven of the ten were food
service industries even included cooks
Bank we putted dishwashers and I'm like
of course that's an easy job you pull it
out you throw the rack over here you
can't put all that in and lump it into
this one stack well she did next clip
Kornegay Robin
workers in America are what okay sounds
about right
and 93 percent of workplace deaths are
men why that's because your chances of
slipping on somebody's Arnold Palmer at
an Applebee's and you serve the runny
spinach dip is far lower than someone
off falling off a roof while they're
installing roof material it's of a
roofing shingles job 966 percent of
tipped workers are women great and
they're making more than the average the
average job isn't that now so now we're
saying majority are women they're making
more the average worker by the way now
if you percent of workplace deaths are
men we're going Europe where this whole
thing again their wages are declining
yeah at the end of this article to it
they're praising two companies that went
away from tipping and just paying their
employees more and one of the companies
that all the servers revolts hit and
wanted to leave because they were making
less money you going that way
they wanted to be rewarded for
performing and you know why that happens
is you could take away tips the good
servers leave yeah they go somewhere
else and then you're left with the
crappy servers and no one wants to go to
your business it's like the fight for 15
yeah exactly
exactly yeah but if you're paying them
15 but they can't even put the Flav fish
on properly no no yeah I'm not letting a
kiosk up front replacing a few you guys
and you're screwing the guy who is
working his way up management yeah
you're screwing the guy who was working
his way up the guy who the guy who shows
up the guy who suits up with his having
a good day or bad day and he says hey
I'm gonna be the best damn server that I
can be you there's there's so much
upwards nobility thanks to free
enterprise in this country you don't
have to you can work in McDonald's for
six months nine months and just not be
in autistic pothead and you will be a
shift manager with pennies okay this is
this and I hate to do this because it's
like it's one of those things I don't
want to be that guy who's saying hey you
know let's why are you always blaming
the white man but it's just they're
taking a lie
the idea that tipping is based on
slavery and racism
that into today with a bunch of false
statistics and one Indian lady who
apparently is the authority on all
things tipping pays and waivers and then
using that to paint with a broad brush
our economy is unfair and the system is
corrupt in the deck is stacked against
you because of white men who didn't even
create tipping in the United States and
didn't create slavery either but who's
doing the most to ensure that servers
make more I hate this but when you put
aside everything it's white male
Republicans we're statistically the best
tippers points penile as we say in
French Canada that's it that's all pack
it up send it on back to missus tiramisu
and or say in the Upper East Side hey if
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit comp
slash mug Club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than six dollars a month
and you get daily content no more clips
Plus this hand at smug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside